hello welcome to have annealing code
Tecna toriel's my name is Matt and doing
one from the car things have been a
little crazy for me lately and not in
the best way dealing with the loss in
the family so sorry I haven't posted in
a while yeah I don't really want to go
into more detail than that at the moment
but it's been it's been a lot and it's
been
something I've been trying to wrap my
head around so anyway I wanted to do a
quick video I it was on the top of my
head and I've been recently in the job
market now I'm and I should preface this
by saying I'm not exactly desperate to
find a new job and I have my reasons for
that
but I've noticed a trend I updated my
resume overall things are I think pretty
strong on there to be a mid-level or
almost even senior level developer and
I've gotten a lot of calls now all I
really did was update my resume put it
up on monster under software developer
engineer and put it up on career builder
under software developer engineer
and I started getting a lot of calls now
the first day after updating it it was
like 10 calls and then it was nine and
they're kind of slowly dwindling a
little bit day by day and after about
two weeks here I'm getting somewhere
around a call or two or did a day now
I'm purely giving this info for for your
information so I'm not trying to brag or
anything like that maybe some people get
more maybe some people get less it
probably depends on how how many job
openings there are for you and who calls
is nine the company that is hiring it is
always a sore third party that's trying
to match you up with a company and then
they get their middle cut that's just
how it works some people really dislike
that and have strong animosity towards
the middleman but if you want to go
apply to a company directly you can
if you want to passively get a job
without trying then yes someone's gonna
get paid in the middle for cooking it
hooking that up and that's that's good
because it gives you the option and you
don't have to take the option you can go
hunt a job yourself and not have someone
else hook it up but the the guy in the
middle the recruiter is a good thing
it's a good option to have because you
can literally just update your resume
and calls will come in and it's that
easy you don't have to go apply do main
things and to have that option is
amazing and you can find some pretty
good jobs and some of them are
contractor I or most of them are that
sort of thing but you never know and
depends it just depends on your field
and stuff so and now I want to get to
the part where I talk about why I
haven't taken a job Jeff one long beard
here that's off topic all right well
so I live in sort of a remote town it's
a little college town and there's not a
whole lot of opportunities here there's
a few kind of specific opportunities
mainly the university itself but they
don't often contract the higher type
people it's pretty rare so they don't
often pop up for these recruiters to
find jobs where they're usually posting
their own jobs and hiring from who
either comes from the school or
opponents directly
returned my wipers up okay so
I have some ties to this county this is
a little town so I can't just up and
leave and I'm not willing to commute an
hour a day or more or anything like that
that's that's a little ridiculous so I'm
trying to I'm trying to do something
either remote or something locally to
this small town and pretty much every
call I've gotten some of them have been
really good opportunities but they're at
least an hour drive some up are even in
other states and basically you have to
be willing to relocate to take any of
these jobs you get from recruiters
because they're often hiring for big
companies big big companies I've seen a
couple that are Microsoft from over in
Washington opportunities obviously I
can't do that that's way too far that's
like across the country for me
and I've seen quite a few that are an
hour away or an hour and a half away
there are really good opportunities and
stuff I really like to take but there's
no way I'm driving an hour to and from
every day and well I have a kid that's
in school and I'm the primary caretaker
so there's just a 0% chance that for any
amount of money I'm going to make that
big of a jump even if they offered me a
million dollars I would just say no
because it doesn't work you can't work
it's like I'll give you a million
dollars to cut your child out of your
life it's like what no there's no amount
that that's gonna work for so that's
been the deal-breaker for me and every
single opportunity I've got from these
recruiters now if you aren't tied down
to something
I pretty much guarantee that you can
make your resume the best it can can be
put all your little side projects on
there everything if you don't have a
whole lot of other work experience and
I'm talking specifically about software
developer software engineer or even web
developer you will find opportunities
you will at least get shots and jobs and
and they'll they'll have you come in and
as long as you give your best when
you're interviewing in and all that
stuff you're going to land something
[Music]
especially if you're willing to relocate
that's that's the big stopper for for me
at least and I'm willing to bet a lot of
other people it's a lot of people are
just tied down I am in that category so
that's been my experience with
recruiters and trying to get a job from
just posting my resume up and waiting
for calls thought I'd give my experience
and and I don't know point of view of
this I don't know if there were a whole
lot of others that are super honest
about it a lot of people seem to have
their own oh what's the right word I
guess I don't know a lot of people seem
to really dislike the whole recruiter
thing and I think it's a great option
like I said I really I don't see the
downside in it so I don't understand
what everybody's people problem are they
just have to look at the reality of the
situation and accept it for what it is
and see that it's not bad it's just
another option
so being that it's just an option you
don't have to take it you can if you're
the type who wants to work for a
specific company you can go do that and
you don't have to touch a middleman but
if you just want to be passive about it
you have that option - all right well
that's gonna do it for this video let me
know what you think
and all that stuff if you want it if you
want to see more of this type of content
please let me know there's things I
could do like I could record some of
these conversations I have with
recruiters if you guys are interested in
hearing that sort of stuff or seeing
some of those just let me know I don't
get a whole lot of requests at the
moment so you know I'm pretty much open
to almost anything that comes in at this
point I've reached a point where I have
over 150 subscribers which kind of blows
my mind that now they think about it I'm
just some guy like posting some of my
experiences and summit Orioles and to
have a hundred and fifty sixty people
say hey I want to see what you do next
is pretty amazing
I don't have that many in real life you
know I have my few friends surrounding
me and that's that's pretty much it but
nobody nothing to the amount of 150
people anyway I'm out have a good day
guys and keep it real